this is a polynomial pleasure I'm
interested in the soulfia okay now you
might remember this is not just any
point it's a cubic can tell by the power
up here right and cubics are kind of
gross we didn't like cubics quadratics
are great super easy the cubix are
terrible right in fact complex numbers
were polly designed to deal with kitties
the cubic formula even if all the roots
of your cubic are all real the formula
for cubic equations has complex numbers
in it okay this is a long story to do
that what can I do with this what on
earth does it have anything to do with
what we've been doing recently okay
any suggestions yeah okay I can make a
substitution now maybe you're not like
hairy and you look at that thing what on
earth would make you think to do that
well number one it but secondly secondly
there is a clue in the question and I
admit it's a fairly vague clue but now
you know enough to recognize it
see those coefficients there hey
negative six a negative six familiar
already I see them yeah I see them you
see that it's just that I need to double
them and then I get eight and negative
six
not only that but there's a huge and in
this is the power of one you see that
okay now it immediately have a bit of
stretch but but for you now but after
you get used to this oh okay this is a
tool I can use right so here's the step
I'm going to suggest let's make this
substitution okay
remember I told you in mathematics your
purchase something for another angle you
can often gain insight right let's have
a go if I let X equal plus theta the
straight substitution looks like this H
cos cube
- one okay so far so good looking at
what I know and how similar that is to
this I am going to take this one over
here so if I add one to both sides it
leaves me with this and now I'm going to
anyone I'm going to take out a factor to
LA and then I might as well divide
through while I'm doing that okay so if
I divide through by that common factor
that leaves me with this and then
because I just spit all this time
proving this I've got this now this is
amazing
just before we proceed just look at what
you achieved this thing what were you
gonna do with that how are you going to
factorize that I'm just going to stop
before it in numbers you will actually
have learned in you've done plot notes
in the extension one haven't you yeah so
you know when you get given a random
cubic right you actually the the main
thing we suggest is stop throwing some
numbers at it right and the factor
theorem the factor theorem should tell
you if for example I throw two into this
right after to it and then I get zero at
the other end what does the factor
theorem tell me if I threw two in that
means X minus two we have factored right
and once you've got X minus two
you say okay I'm gonna have to pull out
that polynomial division thing which
takes a half-page - right but at least I
can do it at least I can do it I can
divide this by whatever you got right
and then you'll get a quadratic out the
other end and you can work with that
those are all so here's the problem uh
you can't do that with this right this
has no it has no integer roots no
integer is so you're gonna throw one and
two and three and then negative one
two and A three and you're gonna keep on
going till the cows come home you will
never guess this solution but by just
very subtle use of this like is this a
high question I mean it's a bit weird
it's not hard we've done harder than
this okay so we've tended very an
insoluble problem into a fairly
straightforward one
what should I do next yeah I should
solve this for three three done right
three theta
yeah is it bad number I'm gonna stop
this at 3 theta what values of three
theta if you take clothes of they won't
give you a half okay okay so I can I can
make sixty degrees right and if I have
the graph right this is here's there's a
half right so there's 60 so just look at
the symmetry of the diagram where's the
other solution it's 300 like forward
backwards right or if you wanted to
think about it that way you're saying
first quadrant fourth quadrant yeah are
you with me now the sorry 60 and 300
they're fine but I'd like to think
ingredients on mom's trying to get used
to this so 60 is gonna be PI 3 300 is
gonna be 5 PI 1 3 very good because it
is five times that now just pause for a
minute we're so used to solving from
Norton 360 not to 2 pi at this point
we're like yeah those are those are
solutions right but we know there are
more right and in fact something that
we've learned in extension to clues us
into the fact that they have to be more
and not just more but how many this
should be exactly one more right because
the fundamental theorem of algebra tells
me this seam should have three roots I
should be able to find all of them now
I've only written down to four reasons
they'll become clear in a minute maybe
you can't anticipate now
lessons I'm gonna write four of them
rather than three just just so I can
contain myself that I've gone all of
them what would the next one be I think
it's gonna be seven pi on three
I've got everything within one period
okay and then to get to the next one
I'll add 2 pi of that and then to get to
the fourth one I'm gonna add to part of
this what's I don't you pay that it's 11
pi over 3 dot okay good I've got I've
got four solutions written down I'm
expecting one of them should be a
duplicate right so let's find out I
solve for three theta so I better solve
for theta now what do I do survive my
fate so that was not hard
food at this point remember we were
working out roots of unity and I wrote
down an extra Ruth do you remember that
and then I found that this last one I
wrote down was exactly 2pi more than
this one so you like up cool it's done I
don't need to worry about that one it's
a repeat but this root is not 2 pi more
than any of these roots right so if it's
a duplicate it's not a duplicate because
of periodicity ok now I want you to
think right 11 PI or 9 where is this on
my graph I've got naught to 2 pi what
did you play that's PI halfway through I
need a new color to get a bit confusing
here's PI everything is on dying right
so the Midway is actually 9 PI on 9 do
you agree with that yes ok let's have a
look at where these solutions are high
on 9 it's like a small angle 5 PI 9 now
look at these two for a second look at
them where are they
here's nine PI online so 7 pm-9 is just
a little bit this way it's your great 11
PI online is the same distance in the
opposite direction do you notice that
now look at cosine look at it cause 7 pi
9 and call is 11 PI 9 are the same
number you can go ahead and you can
punch it into your calculator the angles
are not the same but they're cosines are
the same
so when I look at this right I'm gonna
say we solve for three theta that was
good
we're self vina that was better but my
original question had no theatres in it
so what am I gonna do to try and close
this off I've got to go back yeah I've
got to go back get out of fetus get out
of there right so I'm gonna say
therefore X is going to be cos PI on 9
cos 5 PI or 9 because seven pilum 9 the
last angle I have written is this one
but go ahead
throw it in your calculator and you will
find that these two are the same
okay so therefore I do not need to
include them because it's a cubic the
fundamental theorem of algebra tells us
there should be exactly three roots I
should really be informal and I found
them okay no it's pennies on just so you
can see this is really cool right
remember I told you like this is up what
are you doing here lesson right now
here's the reason why it is so very
difficult to work with cubes okay you
looked at this and you're like oh maybe
I can guess the solution and get
something like that and you can't write
maybe I can get some like square roots
out of this well no you can't your
answers here they're weird
like who's who's sitting there guessing
laughs over the fact it there I'll put
in close pie on nine now is that was
like my next guest okay you're never
gonna guess these solutions cubics a
stranger business than that okay now I'm
just tending on this projector it's warm
enough cuz I want to show you what these
numbers are maybe if you had to
calculate in there you can work them out
for me before I get there but I want to
show you where the solutions are now
this cubic a zoomed in a little bit just
a conservative in this cubic is a X cube
minus 6x minus 1 right and what we solve
is where that cubic equals 0
there they are right now something
that's interesting is the cars power
line pile on line is an acute angle
right it's less than PI on to okay so
that's why it's positive maybe it's just
less than 1/2 somewhat can someone get
the decimal value for that plus PI ninth
that make this cars 20 degrees yeah Oh
degrees oh yes
yeah bigger okay so that's where it gets
me but plus 5 PI 9 plus 7 PI or 9 I'm
negative
that's because look at the angles right
PI on 2 that's 4 and 1/2 PI over 9
that's a right angle but these are
bigger than that so cause of those
angles ends you are negative so you can
see it's quite a it's quite a thing to
take this problem and you know using
very sophisticated tools like this is
completely a real number problem right
it's completely a real lover problem but
we sort of snuck in this other way of
doing it because now all of the stuff
we'll know is your complex numbers ok
does anyone any questions
you got a good ten minutes I won't ask
anymore if you think that to have a look
at exercise 1.6 and have a go at number
one proving a trig identity of your own
with tomorrow's theorem and then
secondly taking one of those results
like like this one here see that one
right and then using in an unusual
context like solving a point of view
okay